how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there has been so much hype about
Avengers in game lately there have been
theories there have been leaks trailers
dropping and it's all really exciting
but today we have some news about phase
4 of the MCU specifically Doctor Strange
- if you're not aware Doctor Strange -
is confirmed and development for it has
started and we now know who the main
villain is going to be in Doctor Strange
- and I'll break that all down in this
video if you're new to my channel I'm
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
there's only 4 days left I'll be
announcing a winner on February 1st so
even though Doctor Strange is kind of
dead right now
Doctor Strange - is confirmed so we know
that he'll be coming back somehow we
learned a couple of months ago that
Scott Derrickson who directed the first
Doctor Strange movie has been confirmed
to be coming back to direct Doctor
Strange - and we have just now learned
that it has been confirmed that see
Robert Cargill who wrote the script for
the first Doctor Strange movie will be
coming back for Doctor Strange - and has
already begun writing the script so
things are really moving for the
development of Doctor Strange - and some
really exciting things come with see
Robert Cargill coming back for Doctor
Strange - and writing the script and
that is the main villain for Doctor
Strange - the last thing we saw in
Doctor Strange was more dough being set
up to be the villain and he will be a
villain in Doctor Strange - but he will
not be the main villain writer see
Robert Cargill stated over a year ago
that he wants the main villain for
Doctor Strange - to be nightmare and
director scott derrickson said that he
would like nightmare to be in a Doctor
Strange film as well when talking about
nightmare he said I really like the
character of nightmare and the concept
that the Nightmare Realm is a dimension
in fact scott derrickson tried to
introduce nightmare in the first Doctor
Strange movie but thought it was a bit
too much to introduce all at once but
now that scott derrickson and see Robert
Cargill are back on board this confirms
that we will be getting Nightmare as the
main villain of Doctor Strange - and of
course like I said mortal will still be
a villain in Doctor Strange - and he'll
have
a pretty big story arc as well here's
what writers see Robert Cargill had to
say about using nightmare and Mordo as
villains at the same time Marvel movies
work in threes they also work outside of
their threes
some of the better Marvel films have
more than one villain in them
me and Scott have not laid the
groundwork for it but what I can say is
that I have a feeling that whatever
nightmare is involved with Baron Mordo
being somebody who considers himself the
defender of natural law will have
something to do with it he goes on to
say for those of you who have ever read
the comics you know that Baron Mordo has
a very particular arc and that's
something we discussed which you would
tell while working on the first movie
and part of the reason she would tell
wanted to play mortal was because he has
a definitive ending as a character and
it's such a fascinating ending and I do
know that whether we're attached or not
that Marvel plans on working towards
that ending and fully realizing Mordo as
more than just a cardboard cutout
villain Bullitt actually taken him to
kind of low key levels of Awesomeness
that's the goal with him so even though
he won't be playing the main villain in
Doctor Strange 2 he is still going to
have a huge role in the sequel
especially if they want to take him to
low key levels of Awesomeness so it's
getting really exciting for Doctor
Strange too we have a director we have a
writer and we have two awesome villains
lined up for the next movie so let me
know your thoughts on this let me know
how excited you are to see Nightmare
enter the MCU let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway and stay up
to date on everything related to Doctor
Strange to Avengers in game in
everything Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]